en cours
pourquoi
autoroutière épousé l'existence
didier pinsky tu mettes sortir ton
premier album il ya tout un buzz autour
de tes chansons
comment il explique sa bosse je pense
humblement que les chansons sont bonnes
je pensais de bonnes chansons puis je
pense que pour moi c'était important qui
est du rythme cliquez de la cadence puis
que ce soit le feu n'en écoutent et qui
sait pas parce que les sujets sont
dramatiques qu'on ne peut pas danser
dessus
[Musique]
sur ton nouvel album soit deux chansons
qui parlent de maladies mentales sont
chics et délicat commente choisi de
raconter son ben justement chanson qui
est justement pas dans d'autres formats
d'or où justement pas dans dans les
conversations si je suis quand même
c'est pas un sujet avec lequel je suis
comme fou la lèze
je pense que pour ceux qui justement
j'écris une chanson c'est pour évoquer
des émotions plus que pour en parler
sans réponse de brazil scrute mes yeux
livre que tu mourir dans son sketch fera
pas de conférence là dessus je ferai pas
comme ça m'a mis là mes amis les plus
proches en parle rapport avec moi ce que
j'ai décidé de le faire c'est de le
canaliser dans une oeuvre d'art qui si
la musique
aux autres sources d'inspiration il ya
serge gainsbourg ouais on attend quoi on
album comme histoire de melody nelson a
vraiment plus d'influencé mais tu vois
le ce que je faisais tantôt le pape à l
équilibre de la pop
pour moi c'est comme ça je reste bon
c'est la quintessence la séquence lui il
le fait il réussit à faire une musique
et original qui plaît qui est populaire
puis en même temps et cpt des tripes qui
sont vraiment cool comme des vieux
albums reggae que tout le monde à y met
il la fait pareil parce que c'est ce
qu'il voulait le faire
jean lepetit libre rouge que tu à
distribuer aux journalistes
ouais je souhaite également harmonium à
andré fortin descola ouais c'est aussi
la musique québécoise a eu un impact sur
toi ben tdd je pense qu'il ya des bons
pour faire des bonnes thoune je suis
rarement d'accord avec ses arrangements
mais je les écoute pas récemment
d'annoncer que ce soit c'est que
l'acteur elle va au dessus des styles au
dessus des modes qui pour moi omnium ces
musiques qui est extrêmement recherché
c'est incroyable c'est surtout c'est
chez sa tante on est la génération peu
de budget c'est surtout quelque chose
qui serait impossible aujourd'hui parce
qu'il ya trop misé sur 5 gt
on dirait que tu as à cheval entre être
un artiste peut être une femme
d'affaires contre tout beau si oui si je
pense que ça demande beaucoup de
flexibilité c'est comme c'est vraiment
que la moitié gauche et droite de mon
cerveau qui sont continuellement conflit
mais je pense que c'est important je
pense que c'est important d'être doit
être être maîtres chez nous
[Musique]
d'avoir les mains dans ses affaires le
bon l'argent passe et je trouve que je
trouve ça important puisqu'ils sont
importants qu'on en parle aussi c'est
souvent quand il parle pas d'argent et
il faut pas mais c'est quand même nous
on est la génération pas de budget c'est
pas on n'a pas le même nez à l'argent
qui est quelqu'un qui a mettons déjà eu
et maintenant une enveloppe qui se la
voit couper c'est sûr que cette personne
là qui appâtent un petit peu plus que
nous on est née puis on s'est fait dire
argent or ça va pas dans mes membres
je pense qu on est hyper créatif à
trouver des moyens de rentabiliser ce
qu'on fait après ce séjour c'est
toujours intéressant de soi lucratif
si on voit l'argent comme une business
être
[Musique]
toujours je pense
parce que l'effet des artistes qui sont
en nombre je peux parler d'argent
l'argent ça me fait chier moi je fais de
l'homme jetons peau est traité dans une
société capitaliste puisse pas avec des
poèmes que tu va détruire le capitalisme
c'est un système qui en ce moment est
trop et amis en ce moment c'est ce
l'effet puis moi en tant qu'entreprise
dans un système capitaliste
j'ai plus de pouvoir qu'un citoyen en
terminant lydia tu as dit avec mon
premier album
ça passe ou ça casse si ça fonctionne
pas il n'y aura pas de deuxième album il
est extrapolé j'ai dit ça passe ou ça
casse mais j'ai pas dit qu'il aurait pas
de souci ça casse parce que ça casse
mais la date non la date
force est de constater que cela
fonctionne très bien d'en face et si le
bouche à oreille fonctionne pour moi
c'est ce qui va être révélateur de sang
fonctionner du d'occuper discute
beaucoup
merci